[Musik]
hallo herr johnson israel heute gibt es
einen basic nämlich einen wunsch rezept
von euch viele fragen mich immer wieder
wie man gemüsebrühe selber macht und
dafür habe ich freude dieses video
gemacht ich zeige euch heute hier die
gemüsebrühe selbst machen kann und vor
allem die ihr sie lagert sowie gemüse
frühen aus bei mir habe ich jetzt so ein
konzentrat gemacht und es wird im
kühlschrank gelagert gibt auch trockene
versionen und auch versionen die
eingefroren werden aber ich sind für
mich diese hier am praktischsten denn
wie kann ich im kühlschrank bewahren und
kann dann einfach immer noch bedarf
bitte macht rauslassen für die gemüse
früher nämlich einfach ganz frisches
gemüse und natürlich gibt es auch fertig
zu kaufen und darauf achten falls
ergebnis gefühl wirklich nichts darüber
machen wollt das ebit einen nimmt ohne
dich mach verstärker ohne
konservierungsstoffe am besten ehrlich
aber immer ganz gerne die von alnatura
genommen dessen zur gemüse darüber führt
oder geschmacksverstärker und vor allem
ohne hefe
denn oftmals verstecken sich die
geschmacksverstärker als hefeextrakt
auch in den fluten
und dann ist da wirklich drauf achten
denn da veräppeln euch einige marken
wirklich sehr aber ich bin mir die
gemüsebrühe geht wirklich ganz einfach
ihr braucht und gemüse dafür und eine
flut von besser das heißt einen mixer
ansonsten müsste er alles ganz fein
schnippeln oder aufreiben ist ein
bisschen mühsam
ich sag jetzt mal was ich dafür
verwendet habe dafür brauchen die
knollen belleri habe starten sellerie
eine stange porree hielt gartenkresse
rote zwiebeln knoblauch nach belieben
chili und ingwer karotten
das ist petersilien wohl führen wenn ein
paar kreuzfahrtschiff schnittlauch geht
magie kraut und hier habe ich noch
petersilie und natürlich verbindet
gemüsesorten und qualität ausgewählt
habe aber ihr könnt euch auch alles
nehmen was der kühlschrank hergibt ganz
wichtig findet allerdings sellerie auch
lieb stecken weil das dieses maggi
gewürzt ist und wie angetrieben
ihr könnt aber zur bedingung für mit der
flug geben natürlich verwenden fenster
das leben paprika dazu geben also
wirklich was im prinzip ist es im
prozess
oder vom einige schon geputzt und
gewaschen und auf
und ich fange jetzt aber mal mit korean
air wird noch gesäubert und vernimmt man
da immer die äußeren blätter erst mal
weg wobei ich mache einen film ab und
halbiert
die tore standen aber normalerweise
nimmt nur weg wenn ich irgendein gericht
damit machen weil die einfach diese
bittere auf sind aber bei der
gemüsebrühe nimmt und wie gerne mit also
verlassen ist drin
und zufällig wird unter fließendem
wasser auswaschen was hier zum beispiel
immer ein paar sandkörner nicht
verschrecken ganze gemüse was hier
verwendet weil ich es grob schneiden und
dann mit dem mixer fein pürieren mache
die platz und da bietet aber vom kopf
geschüttelt
[Musik]
hier oben wird das gemüse ist zwar
kleiner
und das ganze zerkleinerte gemüse geht
in eine große schüssel klaviers gleich
zum mail
[Musik]
ja
zudem staudensellerie gebe ich ja vom
restlichen mit gattin christa und auch
heute
[Musik]
die karotten die klinische zwecke lassen
also ich persönlich witwe mit dazu geben
aber die kinder bei uns natürlich jeden
tag mit essen habe ich jetzt weg und
wirst du dann lieber selber meinen
eigenen teller mit celina fließt hier
auch schon richtig lecker machte mich
früher wirklich eine aromen verbunden
ohne jetzt müsst ihr folgende tun und
zwar bietet dieser gemüse masse erst mal
gewogen und pro 100 gramm gemüse mache
werde ich dann zwölf gramm salz
hinzufügen
die masse gewogen natürlich könnt ihr
jetzt schlauer machen und könnt einfach
ganz gemüse vor dem schneiden und vor
dem klinikum liegen
es gibt mittel einfach aber natürlich
ohne zahlen bei mir etwa 1400 gramm dose
praktisch zwei dollar rechnen als 20
wegstreichen habe ich 14 mal 25 gramm
pro 100 und macht sie 168 gramm wasser
zu geben
das klingt viel aber das team der dafür
dass es eben konserviert wird und nicht
schlecht wird und daher braucht man eben
soviel aus
ganz ruhig ist gut durch und web dann
portionsweise einfach nochmal mit
ich habe jetzt hier übrigens himalaya
von ich hab mich beeindrucken und hat
ganz besonderes mitgebracht aber ich bin
ganz normales meersalz oder haushalts
benutzen das macht nichts denn fit ist
sowieso alles fein püriert
[Musik]
mai
was ihnen die möglichkeiten um die
gemüsebrühe weise zu verarbeiten
entweder könnte jetzt auf ein blech
streifen mit backpapier und dann im ofen
trockenen bedauert aber sechs bis acht
stunden
aber dadurch könnt ihr die instanzen
einfach ein bisschen haltbarer machen
ich finde es gut aber ich muss dazu
sagen da wird viel energie verbraucht
und natürlich auch viel zeit in 68
stunden trocknen lassen ist schon eine
menge
dann gibt noch die möglichkeit das ganze
einzufrieren da findet auch ein bisschen
geschmack und ich mache es jetzt total
ist auch nicht so eine mega große menge
ist werde ich ihnen diese einmachgläser
film und einfach im kühlschrank lagern
durch das ganze fast schon halb war also
etwa bis zu sechs monate ihr müsst
einfach schauen immer mit einem sauberen
löffelrein gehen und bei mir bevor ich
werde doch nicht einzuschränken
das heißt ich mache einfach in zwei drei
monaten noch einmal zeit nehmen wir
einfach die gläser füllt das ganze
hinein und verständlich
[Musik]
b
profitiert die abgepackte gebiete früher
auf und ich bin du siehst ja eine schöne
geschenkidee eingeschränkt auf der kippe
weil sie die gemüsebrühe zubereiten
wollte nehmen wir auf 500 milliliter
wasser etwa 461 natürlich kommt und habt
also je nach intensität ich habe ich
jetzt noch viel drin und es schmeckt
live 50 aber falls man eine ganz starke
früher haben wir also das rezept hastig
laut habe ich erfunden weil stammt von
mir genau das gemacht dass magna alle
haben wir nach dem 8 eine frage sei
natürlich mich versteht er schon überall
als ergebnisse früher gibt es schon seit
jahrhunderten die gemüse viel probieren
ich meinen besser als anderen präsidiert
wie gesagt ist jetzt durch kinderhände
gelangen behälter genau also im
kühlschrank hält sie mehrere monate
aber da die menge ist auch nicht so viel
ist weil man brauche wirklich viele
sechs esslöffeln davon reicht wie eben
bei uns seit neun monaten ein schwacher
bully und man kann hier natürlich
verstecken wenn man noch mehr das so
glauben viele stellen genau und zwar
ganz schwache früheren zum beispiel
genau hier noch ein paar witze mit ein
paar nudeln mittelmeer brühe und da hat
man richtig lecker verdoppeln was soll
ich noch sagen
jetzt gibt's zum nachlesen auf belize -
lockte ihn falls ihr übrigens
bedingungslos mit rein gibt et nich zu
grün
dann wird ein bisschen freundlicher mehr
karotten können dass du das in
friedlicher wird also könnt ihr im flug
selbst bestimmen also viel spaß beim
nachmachen
genau
[Gelächter]
macht
[Musik]
hmm